دائما ما تتكرر الاسئله بشان طائرات اف 16
التي كانت حاضره في تصريحات الدول الداعمه
لاوكرانيا اليوم ولماذا كل هذا الاصرار
عليها كعامل تغيير في مسار المعارك هنا
نسال تحديدا لماذا تريد كياب هذا النوع من
الطيران الجواب لان هذه الطائرات اثبتت
التمتعها بكفاءه عاليه في المعارك فهي
خفيفه ولديها قدرات على القتال الجوي
وتنفيذ ضربات ارضيه اما السمه الاهم بحسب
الخبراء العسكريين فهي انها متعدده المهام
لكن تمت محددات لا يمكن التقليل من شانها
تتحكم بمدى تاثيرها في ميزان المعارك
اهمها تدريب الطيارين والاسلحه التي ستزود
بها وطراز المعدات الالكترونيه المضافه
اليها هذه المعطيات ستحدد سعره وقيمه
وقدره هذه الطائرات وفي حال تم تزويد
اوكرانيا فستكون المانيا وبريطانيا
وبولندا هي المصدر الرئيسي الى جانب دول
اخرى لكن ذلك سيخضع لحساب دقيق جدا نظرا
لمخاوف امريكيه من وقوعها بايدي الروس لكن
ما الذي تملكه اوكرانيا بالاساس من
المقاتلات بحسب تقرير نشر بدايه هذا العام
فان عدد الطائرات المقاتله التي كانت
تملكها كييف تبلغ نحو 200 تقريبا منها
قرابه مئه وخمسه وعشرين طائره من طراز 29
وسوء وسبعه وعشرين لكنها خسرت نحو نصف هذه
الطائرات خلال المعارك لاحقا زودت
سلوفاكيا اوكرانيا بعدد من مقاتلات 129 من
اصل 13 طائره وعدت بارسالها فيما سلمت
بولندا تسعه طائرات بعد ان وعدت بارسال كل
مخزونها من طائرات ميج 29 والبالغ قرابه
30 طائره
معنا الان من عمان اللواء فايز الدويري
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا وسهلا
بك لنفترض ان طائرات افسته عشر وصلت فعلا
كياب الان ماذا ستفعل بها
يعني هو اضافه نوعيه
لانها تؤهلها لخوض ما يطلق عليها بالمعركه
المشتركه بل بحر جو وهذا هو السعي
الاوكراني ان تكون المعركه الهجوم القادم
ليس هجوما بريا فقط انما تحت عنوان
المعركه المشتركه تكون فيها العناصر
الثلاثه الرئيسيه البر والبحر والجو تعمل
بتكامل وعند ذلك يمكن ان تحقق انجازات
ميدانيه يعتد بها وتقود الى طاوله التفاوض
الابسط تتعشر عندما تدخل المعارك كيف
ستغير المعادله الحربيه
طائره
اف 16 هي طائره التفوق الجوي تتميز كما
ذكرت ولكن من اهم مميزاتها القدره على
المناوره صغر الحجم التسارع الايجابي حتى
في الاتجاه العمودي وهي طائره التفوق جوي
اي بمعنى اخر ستمكن من تامين الحمايه
الجويه في المعركه المشتركه للقوات
الارضيه المتقدمه وهي تتفوق على الطائرات
الروسيه من طراز ميك 29 وسوء 30 وما شابه
ذلك اذا وصولها لكن بشرط اعداد كافيه
ومنظومه امداد وطيارين مؤهلين وتقنيه
متقدمه من
الاصدار الخامس ستحدث فرقا واضحا ليست
واشنطن هي من ستمد كييف مباشره دول اخرى
المانيا
بولندا بريطانيا لماذا عبر وسطاء بتقديرك
اعتقد ان السبب تم التصريح عنه من الجانب
الامريكي ان الموازن المخصصه لدعم
اوكرانيا من قبل الامريكيين اذا ما تم
تزويدهم بطائرات اف 16
ستستهلك معظم المخصصات الامريكيه
لاوكرانيا هنا ستجيز باعاده التصدير
وبمعنى اخر التكلفه ستكون على حساب الدول
المصدره وليس على حساب الرصيد الامريكي
المخصص للدعم الاوكراني
شكرا جزيلا لك لو فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي كنت معنا من عمان